[Musique]
c'est une nécessité pour toutes les
nations aujourd'hui
d'avoir une place dans l'espace
ce monde est en train de changer de
façon profonde et surtout accélérée il
s'agit d'orienter ses capteurs dans les
bonnes directions de se poser la
question de savoir quel sera la
prochaine surprise qui viendra de
l'espace
spatial enjeux majeur pour une nation et
nouvelle source de tension
l'espace est aujourd'hui un terrain de
conflictualité comme à terre en mer dans
les airs et dans le domaine cyber
un nouveau champ de confrontation où les
menaces se multiplient
ou séquence la France est mise en ordre
de bataille pour conserver un avantage
stratégique et opérationnel
[Musique]
courroux en Guyane française le 29
décembre 2020 à 7000 km de la métropole
un événement majeur se prépare
dans quelques heures la France va lancer
cso2 un satellite d'observation
militaire aux capacités hors normes
les forces armées en Guyane sont sur le
qui vivent leur mission protéger le
Centre Spatial français installé ici
depuis 1968
c'est l'opération Titan une bulle de
protection renforcée est activée à la
fois terrestre maritime et aérienne
terre les légionnaires du troisième
régiment étranger d'infanterie quadrille
la zone jusque dans ses moindres recoins
avec des équipements adaptés au terrain
en quoi des kayaks à pied ou en véhicule
chenillé
ou depuis sa tour de guet à son sommet
un missile solaire Mistral pour la
défense anti-aérienne
[Musique]
en mer une zone d'exclusion est mise en
place par la Marine nationale sécurité
sécurité ici le patrouilleur de la
Marine nationale qui vous informe d'un
tir de fusée le lundi au-dessus du
Centre Spatial le ciel aussi devient
inaccessible grâce à l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace
le Centre spatial guyanais aujourd'hui
c'est 700 km². donc c'est un travail
colossal donc les forces armées en
Guyane sont chargées de la protection
externe du Centre Spatial du année
l'opération Titan elle s'est à peu près
aujourd'hui 250 à 300 personnes on peut
monter jusqu'à 400 personnes lorsque
l'on a des tiers vraiment spécifiques le
dispositif est mis en place quelques
jours et quelques heures avant les
lancements de façon à neutraliser
l'ensemble de la zone et faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait plus d'individus ni au sol
ni en l'air ni dans les approches
maritimes
c'est une mission qui est remarquable de
par sa technologie
en salle Jupiter la tour de contrôle de
la base spatiale la concentration des
équipes opérationnelles est à son comble
ce lancement c'est l'aboutissement de
plus de 10 ans de travail pour les
spécialistes du spatial militaire
les enjeux sont importants le satellite
cso2 doit être un atout majeur pour les
armées la spécificité de ce lancement
aujourd'hui c'est que les images qui
vont être fournies par cso2 vont avoir
une résolution encore meilleure que
celle offerte par CSOA c'est donc une
étape très importante dans le programme
musicien.o que la Direction générale de
l'armement conduit en équipe intégrée
avec le commandement de l'espace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc évidemment c'est une c'est une
immense joie c'est une grande fierté
d'être ici aujourd'hui et de terminer
cette année 2020 qui a été quand même
pour le moins compliqué pour tous par ce
très très beau succès on a mis en vol un
satellite magnifique qui va nous
procurer des images une qualité
extraordinaire on est très impatient de
voir ces images maintenant nos
opérateurs militaires sont derrière leur
console déjà j'imagine en train
d'attendre ces images même si ça va
prendre un peu de temps mais avant les
équipes en charge du projet ont encore
un peu de travail
pour le comprendre retour en métropole à
Toulouse capitale européenne de
l'industrie spatiale c'est ici qui est
situé le Centre national d'études
spatiales le CNES co architecte du
système CSO avec la Direction générale
de l'armement la DGA
ensemble ils ont défini les
caractéristiques principales du
satellite
nous avons défini en particulier le type
de prise de vue qui allait être réalisé
donc dans le visible dans l'infrarouge
avec une capacité couleur stéréoscopique
nous avons aussi défini donc les
performances associées donc en termes de
résolution en termes de
capacité mais aussi en termes de
réactivité
pour s'assurer que CSO fonctionne
parfaitement bien les experts du CNES
passent en revue tous ces paramètres
sa capacité à prendre des images
infrarouges par exemple
ces activités donc de mise en oeuvre de
l'infrarouge se déroule sur environ
trois jours elle consiste à activer le
contrôle thermique de l'instrument à
tester les électroniques à refroidir les
détecteurs afin de pouvoir prendre les
premières prises de vue infrarouges
maintenant que ces premières images
infrarouges ont été acquises les équipes
qualités images du CNES sont en capacité
de qualifier régler étalonner
l'instrument donc on va qualifier au
travers de différents profils de prise
de vue qu'on va prendre dans les
prochaines semaines pour qui vont
permettre à la fois de s'assurer de la
qualité de l'image la qualité visuelle
que ça réponde bien aux besoins des
utilisateurs mais aussi sa performance
et à notre capacité à prendre telle ou
telle prise de vue
cso2 est doté d'une fonctionnalité
nouvelle le contrôle d'orbite autonome
il est capable de pivoter sur lui-même
pour se maintenir un poste une
intelligence embarquée rendue nécessaire
par les conditions de l'environnement
difficiles à 480 km d'altitude
cette innovation a commencé il y a
plusieurs années au CNES puisque nous
avions réalisé une démonstrateur sur un
statut du CNES où nous avions démontré
ça faisabilité et donc cet exemple il
est assez caractéristique parmi tant
d'autres sur CSO de l'implication des
ingénieurs du CNES sur tout le processus
d'innovation parce que le process
d'innovation c'est pas que trouver des
nouvelles idées c'est un processus qui
est complet où ça va du besoin
utilisateurs bien comprendre bien
évidemment aux premières idées à la
phase de développement avec une phase
qui est très importante pour le spatial
qui est la qualification pour le bol
l'exploitation est bien évidemment le
retour d'expérience vers les missions
futures
pour la première prise de vue terrestre
visite plus infrarouge sur Brest la
constellation CSO et la première étape
d'un renouvellement complet de la flotte
de satellites militaire
pour nourrir cette ambition 700 millions
d'euros supplémentaires sont alloués par
la loi de programmation militaire d'ici
2025 portant à 4,3 milliards d'euros au
total les investissements du ministère
des armées dans le spatial
[Musique]
pour les armées du monde entier les
moyens spatiaux sont devenus
indispensables pour recueillir du
renseignement surveiller le terrain
communiquer et naviguer il y a toujours
eu une compétition pour l'accès à
l'espace depuis le 1er satellite en
orbite Sputnik 1
lancée par les Russes par l'Union
soviétique et depuis cette époque il y a
une compétition qui peut être pacifique
ou qui peut être moins pacifique parfois
parce que les enjeux stratégiques
importants
[Musique]
depuis toujours l'espace fascine pour la
France le rêve devient réalité en 1965
sur la base d'amagir en Algérie la fusée
diamant a mais sur orbite le premier
satellite français Astérix développé
sous la maîtrise d'ouvrage de la
délégation ministérielle pour l'armement
un succès voulu par le général de Gaulle
et qui ouvre à la France la porte du
club très fermée des puissances
spatiales constituées alors des
États-Unis et de l'URSS
pendant la guerre du Golfe entre 1990 et
1991 la quasi-totalité du renseignement
images est apportée par les États-Unis
en 1995 un programme d'observation
spatiale viendra donner à la France son
indépendance stratégique Hélios le
recours aux satellite par les armées
françaises connait alors une croissance
ininterrompue
ça vous donne à la fois une capacité à
voir une capacité d'élongation une
capacité à comprendre et une capacité à
agir qu'aucun qu'aucun autre domaine ne
peut fournir et cela du niveau politique
au niveau le plus bas au niveau tactique
pour les unités qui sont déployées sur
le terrain des capacités renforcées par
la constellation CSO
derrière la réalisation de ces trois
satellites deux industriels européens
principaux Airbus defense and space
maître d'oeuvre des satellites et Thalès
aleniaspace qui fournit les instruments
optiques
ce matin-là à Cannes les équipes de
Thalès aleniaspace finalisent la mise en
conteneur de l'instrument optique de
cso3 le troisième satellite de la
constellation CSO avant son transfert à
Toulouse chez Airbus defense and space
fermeture demain matin pour la fermeture
on est bon on est bon on est dans les
temps hier on a préparé l'instrument CSO
comme il fallait et là on est arrivé
dans le saint ce matin on est parti sur
le conteneur ce matin tout va bien on
est dans les
on est très fiers de cet instrument
c'est c'est assez extraordinaire les
images qui qu'on a eu la chance de voir
quelques petites images c'est vraiment
dingue j'avais les poils comme ça c'est
vraiment
les opticiens ils ont vraiment des
nouvelles manières de travailler qui
font qu'ils arrivent à la pointe de
technologie extraordinaire donc ça oui
ça ils sont on s'en rend compte quand
même qu'on est vraiment sur un niveau
au-dessus
la résolution précise des satellites CSO
et confidentiels doté d'optique dernier
cri ils sont capables de fournir des
images de meilleures résolutions et plus
rapidement
bonjour à toutes et à tous pour cette
troisième et dernière revue de livraison
CSO le dernier modèle
le premier satellite CSOA est
opérationnel depuis deux ans il est
positionné sur une orbite à 800 km et
contribue à la mission reconnaissance il
sera rejoint sur cette orbite par le
satellite cso3 en 2022
le deuxième satellite cse2 est dédié à
la mission
identification il est placé sur une
orbite plus basse à 480 km ce qui lui
permet d'offrir une résolution encore
meilleureites en termes de réactivité et
de qualité des images en particulier
la précision et la résolution des images
identification est inédite en Europe
dans le cadre de la construction de
l'Europe spatiale de la défense CSO est
ouvert au partenaire européen depuis le
lancement du premier satellite en 2018
l'Allemagne la Suède la Belgique et
l'Italie ont déjà rejoint la communauté
csso et en échange de l'accès de
l'Allemagne de l'Italie à la capacité
CSO la défense française pourra utiliser
les satellites radars de ces deux pays
trois satellites sans oublier leur
centre de contrôle le système CSO se
sont aussi des stations au sol qui
permettent de commander et de recevoir
des images
l'imagerie spatiale constitue l'un des
piliers du renseignement d'intérêts
militaire elle permet d'observer des
zones d'inaccessibles aux avions ou au
drone des yeux indispensables pour aider
les militaires déployés sur le terrain
et assurer une veille stratégique
mondiale
c'est la Direction du renseignement
militaire la DRM utilisateur principal
du système qui a le contrôle
opérationnel de CSO
il faut évidemment faire la distinction
entre la fourniture d'une image et la
fourniture d'un renseignement le rôle de
la Direction du renseignement militaire
outre le fait de livrer une image
notre plus-value est évidemment de la
valoriser et donc dans l'extraire
l'information essentielle vue du ciel si
on n'est pas spécialiste on peut pas
forcément faire grand-chose d'une
certaine image et donc c'est vraiment
notre rôle de renseigner de
pré-enseigner ce que nous voyons sur
cette image pour répondre à la question
que nous a posé le demandeur qui lui n'a
pas demandé qu'une image il a évidemment
une question en tête chaque jour a crée
dans le Val-d'Oise les équipes du centre
de formation et d'interprétation
interarmée de l'imagerie produisent et
fournissent du renseignement à partir de
l'imagerie spatiale
était touché et qu'il a entièrement été
détruit hormis la queue je pense que il
faut faire un petit un petit bride qui
passe les étages et du coup c'est dans
le monde de l'imagerie et de la
reconnaissance on a un triptyque
détecter reconnaître
identifier
c'est savoir répondre à la question
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose à un
endroit X ou Y oui a priori il y a un
véhicule il y a quelque chose
reconnaître il y a quelque chose et je
sais que c'est un char de combat
identifié je sais vous dire quel est le
type de char de combat ou d'avion ou de
navire etc avec CSO mes spécialistes
vont être de plus en plus affirmatifs
dans l'analyse des scènes qui vont avoir
à décrire et à analyser pour les experts
la nouvelle génération de satellites
d'observation militaire CSO constitue
une avancée majeure dans l’analyse des
images notamment du fait de ses
capacités infrarouges qui lui permettent
de traquer toute signature thermique des
objets ou des sites observés
un exemple des avions alignés sur un
parking en plein soleil en journée
je sais dire sur une photo optique oui
il y en a 10 mais si à côté de ça je
regarde l'image rien infrarouge et bien
je peux peut-être dire que c'est bizarre
parce qu'il y a des ombres au sol qui
m'indiquent que quelques minutes
auparavant il y avait d'autres avions en
fait c'est pas 10 il y en avait 15 ce
genre de choses ça peut être d'autres
exemples peut-être plus sur des sites
dit industriels avec des infrastructures
de la tuyauterie des cuves des choses
comme ça en fonction de ce qui va y
avoir dedans plein vide la signature en
infrarouge sera différente et moi dans
l'analyse qui va être faite par mes
spécialistes et bien les conclusions
seront pas les mêmes autre apport de CSO
le nombre d'images mise à disposition
des experts du renseignement par rapport
à Hélios c'est plusieurs centaines
d'images accessibles chaque jour contre
quelques dizaines auparavant
moi ce qui m'importe dans ce flux
d'image c'est d'être sûr de mettre
l'effort sur les bonnes priorités et
très concrètement ce qu'on est en train
de vivre cette transformation cette
révolution parce que à mon sens c'en est
une c'est de passer d'une phase
d'observation à quasiment une phase de
surveillance
face à un tel volume de données les
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
vont jouer un rôle important dans les
années à venir une plateforme appelée
Taya est en cours d'expérimentation à la
DRM
son rôle traité les images issues des
satellites CSO et détectés
automatiquement la présence d'objets
d'intérêts
les anomalies ou les activités anormale
ça va nous faire sortir des alertes
qu'on peut regarder par nous-mêmes du
coup et ça nous permet d'avoir un indice
sur quel site et nouvellement actif ou
anormalement plus active des choses
comme ça on va être sur une image du
coup de 2019 alors en l'occurrence ici
on peut voir les différentes sous zones
qui ont été créées sous le site donc ça
va être tous les quais les bassins et en
fonction du coup on aura différents
navires en l'occurrence là qui vont être
détectés par Taya on a du navire de
guerre on a dynamivers civile de
marchands et à chaque fois qu'un nouveau
navire va être détecté il apparaîtra
dans ce tableau en fait des alertes et
tous les points rouges c'est de
l'activité inhabituelle en l'occurrence
il y en avait un de plus que d'habitude
0 pour les navires de guerre mais par
exemple ici à cette date en 2018 on a pu
en avoir trois l'objectif
ultime au-delà de faire ce suivi et ce
cette surveillance c'est d'arriver à
l'étape suivante qui est d'arriver à
imaginer des scénaris pour faire du
prédictif et c'est bien l'objectif du
renseignement c'est pas tant de décrire
ce qui s'est passé hier mais assurément
d'essayer de d'imaginer et de de
proposer des options ou des perspectives
de ce qui risque de se passer demain un
véritable bon en avant pour le
renseignement militaire
à Paris le centre de planification et de
conduite des opérations le CPCO compte
depuis 2019 un bureau dédié aux spatial
sa fonction intégrer la dimension
spatiale à tous les niveaux dès le stade
de la planification des opérations le
CPCO fait des stratégies opérationnelles
sur les différentes zones géographiques
donc là le but c'est vraiment d'apporter
l'espace dans toutes ces dans tous ces
sujets là ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant de faire également une stratégie
spécifique pour l'espace pour encore une
fois essayer de d'être dans ce processus
d'anticipation et de réflexion et
d'appropriation du sujet espace il y a
également de nouvelles missions qui vont
arriver je citerai l'exemple de l'alerte
avancée spatiale un système qui
perdait et identifié des tiers de
missiles
à initier les travaux dans ce domaine
une vingtaine d'années un démonstrateur
d'alerte avancé a notamment été mis en
orbite en 2009 et exploitée pendant deux
ans
la composante spatiale de cette nouvelle
capacité est au cœur du programme Arès
pour action et résilience spatiale
qu'il soit d'observation d'écoute de
communication ou de navigation les
satellites sont aujourd'hui
incontournables mais ils sont aussi
vulnérables face aux menaces
sur la période il y a des nations qui
poussent la compétition je dirais un peu
plus loin et ce qu'on observe c'est que
l'espace devient un domaine de
confrontation de confrontation possible
entre des puissances militaires il y a
des menaces de nature cyber il y a des
menaces donc beaucoup plus physiques
mais qui reste non destructive ou avec
des effets en tout cas qui sont non
permanents vous pouvez avoir de
l'éblouissement du brouillage vous avez
des menaces non intrusives du de
l'espionnage et puis à la fin dernière
extrémité du spectre vous avez des
menaces
destructrices ou destructive avec des
effets qui peuvent être permanents les
moyens les plus spectaculaires qu'on a
pu observer ce sont les missiles
anti-satellites qui ont été tirés en
tout cas les essais qui ont été faits
par trois nations depuis 2007 et qui ont
montré qu'on savait depuis le sol
tiramicide pour détruire un satellite en
orbite basse après les États-Unis la
Russie et la Chine l'Inde est devenu
récemment le quatrième pays à faire la
démonstration d'une telle technologie
du sol on ne voit pas tout alors comment
faire face à ces menaces venu
directement de l'espace en 2018 la
ministre des Armées Florence Parly
dévoile à une tentative d'espionnage
d'un satellite franco-italien Athena
fidus par un satellite russe
maîtriser l'espace une ambition majeure
de la nouvelle stratégie spatiale de
défense élaborée en 2019 et incarnée par
le programme Arès objectif accroître
notre connaissance de la situation
spatiale protéger nos futurs satellites
depuis la Terre ou l'espace et mener des
opérations spatiales militaires dans le
but de décourager les actes dynamicaux
dans le respect du droit international
la division préparation de l'avenir du
commandement de l'espace recueille et
étudie les besoins futurs en la matière
la division traite des aspects
techniques des capacités spatiales qui
sont en orbite ou qui vont l'être
prochainement aux côtés de l'état-major
des armées des armées et puis de la DGA
elle traite aussi comme son nom
l'indique de sujets plus prospectifs les
besoins des armées de spécifications de
ces futurs capacités spatiales nous
travaillons par exemple notamment sur
les futurs constellations d'imagerie et
des coûts spatiales avec encore une fois
toutes les forces
le nom de ces futurs programmes Cérès
pour capacité d'écoute et de
renseignements électromagnétiques ou
encore Syracuse 4 satellite de
télécommunication qui seront lancés
d'ici 2022 et enfin la division
préparation d'avenir s'occupe de la
définition des besoins en matière de
surveillance de l'espace de protection
des satellites et évidemment esquisse
les contours du futur centre de
commandement et de contrôle des
opérations spatiales
ce futur centre des opérations spatiales
sera localisée à Toulouse d'ici 2025 où
sera regroupé l'ensemble de l'écosystème
du commandement de l'espace les unités
un laboratoire d'innovation spatiale
mais aussi un nouveau centre
d'excellence de l'OTAN
l'idée atteindre la même maturité dans
le domaine spatial que dans les autres
milieux terrestres aériens et maritimes
appréhender une menace dans l'espace
c'est appréhender tout type de
comportement et cela selon une
temporalité d'évolution qui est propre
au domaine spatial le domaine spatial
représente des durées d'opération qui
sont nettement supérieures à tous les
autres domaines opérationnels et c'est
donc la maîtrise de cette nouvelle
boucle temporelle plus complexe plus
difficile à anticiper qu'il faut
maîtriser pour à terme maîtriser les
captés spatiales qui concourront à
défense active de la qualité nationale
de nouvelles menaces et donc de
nouvelles protections à concevoir à la
Direction générale de l'armement
différents moyens de défense spatiale
sont à l'étude ça peut être soit des
actions de défense intrinsèque
c'est-à-dire de technologie qu'on va
embarquer à bord de nos satellites pour
les protéger contre les attaques on peut
penser des dispositifs de simples de
surveillance périmétrique des abords que
chaque satellite sache à peu près ce qui
gravitent autour de lui ça peut être des
dispositifs qui permettent de se rendre
robuste et on peut également parler de
dispositifs de défense extrinsèques
c'est à dire pas directement implémenté
sur nos satellites mais assurer par des
moyens déportés
donc là je pense notamment à ce concept
de satellite getters c'est-à-dire des
petits satellites qui seraient amenés à
graviter autour d'objets stratégiques à
protéger
pour être capable de d'intervenir de
s'interposer en cas de menace
un satellite patrouilleur ou getter avec
une mission veillez sur les capteurs en
orbite géostationnaire
sa gouvernance que l'on veut éprouver au
travers de cet objet c'est on sait que
demain pour mener des opérations
défensives dans l'espace il faudra
certainement maîtriser les technologies
à ce mouvement de façon très précise et
c'est l'un des objectifs premiers de ce
démonstrateur c'est bien de valider les
technologies qui vont nous permettre de
manœuvrer en sécurité le projet Yoda
préfigure une nouvelle gamme d'engins
spatiaux que le ministère des armées
s'apprête à mettre dans l'espace
déconcentrés de technologie qui ne
seront non plus seulement chargées
d'appuyer les opérations sur terre mais
d'agir depuis le ciel et vers le milieu
spatial
la France poursuit son odyssée de
l'espace
[Musique]